[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see them what's
making the headlines with the politics
editor editor of galden moyer lady
mclean and the pr consultant alex dean
welcome to both of you let's check out
the front pages then straight away
starting with the metro come save our
bacon the metro leads on the government
offering six month visas to eu meat
workers to fill gaps in slaughterhouses
meanwhile the telegraph leads on
comments from the department of
transport accusing unions of holding
christmas hostage as unite ballots for
an hgv driver strike demanding toilets
and catering facilities at truck stops
financial times reports that a number of
leading eu member states are urging
brussels to get ready for what it calls
a trade war with britain if the row over
trading arrangements for northern
ireland isn't settled
the daily mail reports her majesty the
queen made a rare public intervention on
the climate change crisis saying she is
irritated by people who talk but don't
do
that's also the main story for the
mirror green queen royal climate change
blast
the times also has a story on climate
with boris johnson reportedly being told
that president xi of china will not
attend next month's critical climate
change summit in glasgow
the guardian reports that gps have said
the plan to increase face-to-face
appointments could lead to an exodus of
doctors
and the style claims a yeti
a yeti has
has been spotted in marbella where boris
johnson
was on holiday we're told he's returned
at the yorkshire post leads on the north
yorkshire police commissioner stepping
down from his post after intense
pressure in the wake of his comments on
the murder of sarah everard and women's
safety
and the daily express carrying a claim
that what it calls miracle drug statins
have emerged as a surprise additional
weapon in the fight against covert 19.
so let's bring in moya and alex welcome
to both of you and straight to the
telegraph unions holding christmas
hostage about conditions for hgv workers
moya
yes i mean this is quite disingenuous
framing is it not uh
this week we've had the prime minister
saying that to attract talent uh certain
industries had to put up wages and have
better conditions and yet on the front
page of the telegraph we're seeing hdv
workers demonized for demanding better
working conditions which does not make
sense to me surely building a better
britain means creating better working
conditions especially in such an
isolating job at a time when we've seen
droves of drivers leave due to these
four working conditions
i i thought they were pushing at an open
door about this it seems to been
recognized in government that actually
you know better toilet facilities even
showers on the roads i mean all of these
things now need to be looked looked at
in comparison with what we're seeing in
europe in order to attract more people
to the position uh alex what do you
reckon
yeah i think that's right i think they
were going to get a lot of this anyway
and i think what they do is risk public
support in taking this position over
christmas of course on the one hand
unions have um always have a certain
amount of sympathy amongst people who
work most especially of course their
members but wider sympathy too and if
you're going to have a protest that you
want to do it at a time when it's going
to have an impact that's on the one hand
on the other hand you can get a sense
sometimes when an union overplays its
hand and you saw that when government
was much more confrontational with the
unions back in the 1980s and
occasionally um you've seen it uh since
i think the comparison i would draw
would be with azlev when they were
trying to um get better deals for train
drivers and withheld their labour much
the chagrin of commuters i think they're
going to get this kind of activity
anyway i think government's pushing for
better conditions with it for htv
drivers and pushing employers for better
conditions so i really just
pragmatically wonder if this is the
right move yes the the telegraph saying
or quoting a government spokesman uh it
would be reckless for unions to hold
christmas hostage and damage the work
being done to restore supply chains at
this vital time of year um my christmas
once again being held as the pinnacle of
all things towards the end of the year
to be fair but um you know
already we're seeing hgv drivers get
more money it's it's not helping the
shortage though is it in many respects
no because i think what we've seen as
you mentioned europe is that people want
better working conditions that's one of
the key findings that came out of sort
of pandemic realization about the way we
work it's not just money yes we should
absolutely have fair wages but it's also
working conditions these people on the
road for you know
ages they're often isolated and we've
seen truck drivers talk about the lack
of facilities showers you know a hot cup
of tea when they come off [ __ ] uh it
just makes sense to me that we give them
better working conditions and i think
the government trying to put this uh
notion of them stealing christmas or
holding christmas hostage is attempt to
shirk the responsibility to give them
these conditions
uh the government's defense uh is that
much of this has a global nature uh the
containers in the wrong places around
the world obviously uh the the matte
cartoon in the telegraph you don't still
believe in the supply chain crisis do
your parents make it up so they don't
have to buy you christmas presents well
who knows if that's going to end up
being true the independent now online
suggesting it's seen an internal
document from amazon suggesting it will
try and get customers to buy gifts four
weeks early believes that the
difficulties in supply will continue
until the spring
um you know how can this government or
how can governments around the world try
to relieve some of these supply chain
pressures alex
well it's a global problem uh as you say
but we can try and do our best to ease
things at this end and actually i think
more has got a point about uh conditions
for uh drivers in the uk and that's
something we can address after all part
of the point of our current
international situation and brexit is
seeking to make the uk more attractive
not less attractive
people whose labor are whose labour's in
demand but on this one i think that part
of what we can do is issue more hgv
licenses it's clear to me that part of
the problem uh in the last two years has
been that because of code and because of
test set has been closed we haven't
granted um hdv licenses afresh in
anything like enough numbers uh to let
new people come into the profession of
course two we've seen there's a lot of
people in the uk some 300 000 who hold
hgv licenses and aren't attracted back
to it we've got to try and fix that too
but for heaven's sake we've got to speed
up the process of issuing new hdb
licenses to get new talent into the game
as well
well it's not just a global issue is it
moya there is a specific issue in this
country of specific labor shortages hgv
we've talked about poultry work as we
know about butchers abattoir workers
which were really dominated by those
coming from abroad which takes us to the
metro come save our bacon uh the u-turn
to try to get eu meat workers back into
the uk
yes it seems like every week we're
saying one of these stories is it not um
we need about 500 uh butchers and so
there's been a massive youtube and the
story's run on for a while now
boris first responded to it by making
jokes now he's actually decided that you
know we're going to issue these
six-month visas for um workers to come
in because and staff abattoirs because
of the build-up of uh pigs basically and
it's really difficult i think what we're
seeing is farmers have been struggling
since brexit the pandemic has compounded
that and it feels very disrespectful on
the part of boris johnson to have been
making these jokes do a u-turn and still
not offer any sort of long-term support
for this industry which is at an
absolute rock bottom and he supposedly
wants to make this the bedrock of
post-brexit britain but all we're seeing
is a disrespect
yes i mean is is that true do you think
that this government's become overly
reactive and not proactive george eustis
today saying that he'd been speaking to
those in the pig farming industry for
the last 10 days they've been warning
about this for way beyond 10 days
haven't they alex you know they do they
need to get on top of some of these
things
well my instinct is that actually this
is how brexit is supposed to work that
you there is a need in the workforce and
then using discrimination in the proper
sense of the word the uk calls upon
those that we want to come and serve a
labor need in our market you might say
that's taking back control rather than
having a an open door the door is open
to those who have specific qualities or
qualifications that the uk needs on your
point i mean george eustis knows the
agricultural industry exceptionally well
farmer himself and i'm sure the
government has been on top of these
questions but of course in the end part
of the unprecedented movement of labor
not just in this country and brexit
related or even just in europe but
around the world has been affected
profoundly by coronavirus people
returning home who used to send
remittances home because they wanted to
be close to their families and they
wanted to be with them in tough times
we've seen this all around the world in
asia huge population movements in india
and in china so that really is a global
issue you can argue that we're not
getting our response completely right
i'm not sure any state is in the current
uh pandemic post-pandemic environment
but specific uh
visas for specific workers at specific
times that's exactly how brexit's
supposed to work yeah but the problem is
you don't click your fingers and presume
they come because as we've seen with the
hgv visa offer that has not happened
alex
yeah well you've got to make it
attractive right so back to the point
that moyer was making rightly not just
about working conditions which is
something for us as a country to address
but also about pay and who's been urging
those employers to pay uh their staff
more the government so actually you're
right you don't click your fingers and
get it to happen but i do think you will
see uh you've got to look to what the
government is doing right as well as
what you would say it's doing wrong i
still say you can go further i think we
could have tax cuts to incentivize
people come and work in the united
kingdom let them keep more of their own
money and make us more attractive from
that perspective but yes i think
government's doing the right thing
okay instead of pay for visas and
accommodation which uh some have said
will run to the very many tens of
thousands um so we've done hgv drivers
uh crisis some might say we've done
supply crisis we're moving on to energy
crisis now the cost of gas obviously of
real concern for consumers and for
businesses and uh quasi quoting in both
the ft and the telegraph in fact um
suggesting that he has seen
documentation showing room for a mild
winter windy wet and mild which might
ease the cost of living fears of those
rising gas prices moya
i can't imagine
anyone could read the story and not
think anything but scornful thoughts
uh it is absolutely laughable to me that
we have a government minister saying
it's okay about these rising living
costs because we're going to rely on the
mercy of the weather to struggle through
the bleak mid-winter it does not make
sense for the government who hold the
purse strings and have the ability to
support households this winter to be
bleating about mild weather as a get out
clause there's roughly i think 8 500
deaths a year due to cold temperatures
in winter it was up 20 in 2020 so that
was then that was considered a mild
winter even a mild winter caused the
pipes in my house to freeze what is
going to happen to those who can't
afford to heat their homes well the the
ft says mr quarten showed the energy
suppliers a met office briefing i know
we all want to know the forecast which
said for the late winter period from
january to february 2022 the most likely
scenario is for an unsettled period of
wet windy and mild spells but one
official said our plan to protect
consumers isn't based on weather
outlooks whatever happens the energy
price cap will remain in place to shield
consumers from high global gas prices
because the real fear is that the next
time the energy price cap changes
it will go up by what up to another 400
pounds when it's next reviewed alex
you're talking big money for people now
yeah well look he's not wrong that the
weather is important is he we know that
that plays a significant role in
everything from nhs hospital admissions
to our ability to provide
gas and fuel to people's homes but the
bigger problem here which i think is
twofold is the one that you've
identified about gas prices which means
that a lot of businesses can't stay
afloat with the current international
price they're paying
for basic commodity
at the price they're allowed to sell it
in the uk market problem one and problem
two that we don't have enough long term
reserves and when i say long term i mean
weeks not you know months or years ever
since we closed rough which was the last
real gas facility in the uk for storage
on any significant scale we've had a far
smaller gas
capability
in our storage systems than any other
developed country and if you take those
things together it adds up to a
potentially really big problem because
if that bet is wrong about the weather
and we
go short on on fuel then you've got a
real problem and in the end if we think
we're going to be able to rely on things
like lng imports from abroad part of
that gets shut down because we then get
outbid by other countries who are draw
the ships to them they're closer and
they pay more so the ships break their
shipping companies break their contracts
and go there in the end in part this is
due to our rush to decarbonize which has
been done for the best possible motives
but we've done it as a country the same
time we haven't invested enough in
nuclear we haven't really invested
enough in our resources and our ability
to uh maintain uh supply even for weeks
and things like gas and it's coming now
i'm afraid to bite us well gas storage
has been on the agenda for years hasn't
it so i'm not sure uh that the
decarbonization had anything to do with
that but uh
but you know it's it's an interesting
entry for boris johnson when he hits his
desk come friday morning certainly stay
there lots more to come including the
queen's green anger her majesty backs
prince william in criticizing world
leaders for all talk and no action
[Music]
i'm greg milam skye's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
can you go away we take you to the heart
of stories that shape our world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
police have just made their first move
and they're following firing
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across
[Music]
gansung that's what's left of the north
tunnel uh where the north koreans
exploded five nuclear warheads
[Music]
and this is a show of strength at a time
when china is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
shrapnel from that explosion so you can
see it littered along all the way we
take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our
the world station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports that they are
being blocked by police so we're going
to try and find a way out
after five days stranded here this is
deliverance we help you understand the
world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Music]
[Music]
see candace
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now as you can see
the political politics editor rather of
galden more olivia mclean and the pr
consultant alex dean great to see both
of you back so yorkshire post not
surprisingly uh leading once again on
the resignation of the north yorkshire
police and crime commissioner alex
philip allet who made some rather unwise
suggestions over the
murder of sarah everard
he made ridiculous suggestions about
women being streetwise i mean first of
all victim shaming is completely wrong
but second of all what is a victim like
this supposed to have done if she's been
streetwise and been able to ascertain
the identity of the person who'd
accosted her it would have revealed that
he was indeed legitimately a policeman
so what would that possibly have served
he's quite right to have resigned but
it's a perverse outcome for someone who
makes stupid comments like this to go
whilst the person who presides over the
force concerned gets renewed who's made
equally stupid comments like jumping on
a bus if you an officer uh stops you and
you feel unsafe that
the metropolitan police commissioner
gets renewed in office for two years so
whilst it's right he's gone i still
think there's a lot to be done with the
police force uh mr alex suggesting that
uh accepting he had a loss of trust
wanted to build it back again that
people shouldn't be penalized for for
saying one bad thing in a live interview
effectively moya
i mean as they're saying one bad thing
in a live interview and there's making
you know the comments that he made at
such a delicate sensitive time
i think what it also shows is that
the issues we've been talking about
they're sort of endemic
to the policing structure go all the way
up to police commissioners and i think
it's interesting i've heard a lot about
police commissions than their role
recently which was obviously born in
2010 and how sometimes it's a sort of
party political um allegiance that means
police connect commissioners get elected
according to which party they represent
alec was a conservative commissioner as
opposed to perhaps who is really best
for the job so i do think it might be
worth looking at that system as well and
whether it's actually functioning as it
should be let's go to the daily mirror
it's also the lead for the times as well
which reports that president xi of china
is not coming to glasgow something i
think we we probably already knew but um
in the comments they say the queen was
caught on microphone at the senate
on thursday expressing concern
that it was unclear who would be
attending uh in the comments caught by
the microphone i've been hearing all
about cop still don't know who is coming
no idea we only know about people who
are not coming it is very irritating
when they talk but they don't do
you can't
i wonder if i wonder if if that's uh
really an accident it's not treasonous
of me to speculate the royal family for
a long-standing institution they really
get the pr right sometimes don't they
and this about perhaps that's why
they're so long-standing as an
institution this is the queen being very
on message with her with current
thinking and moreover with the thinking
of her son who will be our king and with
her grandson who will one day be our
king too i think that this is a
remarkably astute bit of accidental
commentary
okay and uh prince william of course
already criticizing space tourism he's
launching his earth shot prince charles
is you mentioned has been long committed
to the cause uh all of them heading up
to uh to glasgow as well um a hundred
world leaders but no president xi we
will see shall we um they're sending a
no doubt a diplomatic delegation